if you've been on the internet for a few
years you've probably noticed that some
websites look or act differently on
different browsers in trying to open a
modern website on an older browser
sometimes yields a buggy experience
obviously as web developers we want to
ensure that our users have the same
awesome experience regardless of their
browsers or operating systems this has
been a problem since the beginning of
the web and there are solutions
available to manage cross browser
compatibility if you search for CSS
resetting or CSS normalize you'll run
into this stylesheet normalized at CSS
let's take a look at it this will help
ensure that your CSS styles are
interpreted the same across all browsers
to take advantage of CSS resetting
simply link to the CSS style you see
here like so and you can be confident
that your Styles will work the same
across all browsers